hello everyone its Barry here with
another exclusive Collider interview I
am sitting with Todd Haynes the director
of dark waters how are you doing are you
just like running around like crazy
right now it's all good it's nice I'm
doing very well it's nice too it's
always nice to sit here and talk movies
with just about anybody but you are a
filmmaker I deeply admire and especially
with this project here it's a story that
should be told yes that's exactly how I
felt when it came to me so can you tell
me a little bit about the process of
this coming to you because I know that
this had a very very quick turnaround so
is that a new scenario for you or it's
an experience it was crazy when I when
you actually think back that the thing
that broke it was a New York Times
expose from 2016 I mean that's why
yesterday although it describes a story
that hit me going on for 1618 years
prior to that and a campaign by de Pont
that had been going on for what's
probably now about 60 years with the
production of Teflon
but this story quickly became something
that Mark Ruffalo would became aware of
and participant media and Mark and
participant had worked on on spotlight
not that long before and people were
coming to mark who's an activist and
engaged in environmental issues and
water issues and said you got a look at
this and he did and he immediately
reached out to rob a lot who is the
lawyer from Cincinnati of the story is
about who Mark plays in the movie and
literally within a year after that story
broke 2017 there was a script he sent it
to me I mean this doesn't happen there's
no speeding in movies right you know
this was the key to getting things going
I mean is there is there any specific
reason this got off the ground faster
than other projects I think they saw
what incredible social relevance
a story like this has right with
everything that we're facing today and
the magnitude of the story is so
shocking from how it begins with a
single sort of American beloved product
a flan and famous chemical company
behind it how much began just in sort of
local issues of the water systems in the
Midwest and then it kept spreading and
kept spreading and kept spreading
because of our anti regulatory system
and is ultimately spread across the
globe and PFOA which is the chemical at
issue in the story is now in the blood
of 99% of all living creatures
nightmares I watch that's it's it's not
I watched so many horror movies like
this is the type of stuff that keeps me
up at night seriously this is a true
life Horror Story have you been hearing
a lot of comparisons to Erin Brokovich
because it very different stories and
both very much well well we're telling
but what would you say to someone out
there who is thinking well I saw iron
Brockovich why am I gonna watch this one
Erin Brockovich is a great family main
film and uh and a very engrossing story
with an incredible and charismatic woman
at the center of this story in many ways
this is a more nuanced and subtle and in
some ways it feels more like the stuff
of real life even though of course Erin
Broughton which it's a true story and
she used this and she had all of those
qualities but rob a lot is an unexpected
hero he's not the kind of guy you expect
to take on systems of power because he
came from those systems of power he was
a criminal defense attorney defending
the chemical industry yeah and believed
in regulation and believed that there
was a way that industry and regulation
could coexist and then sort of happened
in Italy all these all the great I think
whistleblower stories are about people
who come out who are in the dark and the
story starts to form and get bigger and
bigger and more astonishing and more
are infuriating right and that rage
fuels the fight yeah and that's exactly
what happens with Rob I feel like these
are very important true stories to get
out there but one of the I'm gonna
answer my own question one of the things
that I appreciate about having both of
them two is they're two completely
different types of individuals she when
she walks into the room she makes her
presence known where whereas he is like
much more quiet and keeps to himself and
I just feel like having both of those
examples out there can tell anybody it
doesn't matter who you are if you
believe in this cause you can make a
difference absolutely and I think no
one's seen Mark Ruffalo quite embody the
skin in bones of a guy like this Rob a
lot you know someone emotionally guarded
and kind of hunched over and kind of
lost in a front perpetual frown who kind
of finds his voice and finds his his
life's work through accidentally right
through circumstances they come upon him
you know Erin Brockovich you sort of
think she'd be capable anything the
minute you meet her mark emerges through
the character of Rob a lot and sort of
finds out who he is you know and I found
that to be so moving and also so painful
because people who are out there
truth-telling mm-hmm they get
stigmatized right and the power systems
start to push back against them and
threaten them and they enter a perilous
place and that's what makes them even
more astonishing their their work did
you always know that he was gonna play
the lead role I mean I always know ever
since he first signed on because I don't
think we reported it until right around
this time last year what's cool I think
is that Mark wanted to Shepherd this
whole project into being from the
vantage point of a producer and really
believed that the story needed to be
told and didn't want to sort of push
himself necessarily as the yeah the
leading sort of banner name attached to
the to the actor but he was and that was
always always a given but but yeah you I
swear to God when you for people first
see him in the movie you they don't even
know it's more
we've even had people talk about the
prosthetic makeup that he wears
of course he wears no personnel yeah
that's all there something about the way
she rounds and it did make me think
twice so it's a it's really did you see
any of just you know the preparation he
went through to kind of make that happen
what was so remarkable for me as a
director I think for the actors for the
for the entire creative team on the
movie is that we surrounded ourselves
with the real people we were in the real
places we were in Cincinnati we visited
West Virginia we had these people on set
they were our advisors you know and and
they come across the class divided from
an Appalachian farmer and park outside
of Parkersburg West Virginia all the way
to the guy who run ended up becoming the
managing partner for Taff law one of the
most one of the most prestigious law
firms in the country and definitely in
the Midwest and played by Tim Robbins
but it was so remarkable to see Rob
spending so much time with mark and Mark
watching him and internalizing him an
interpolating him you know and maybe
other amazing thing is to watch the real
Rob a lot start to uncoil himself yeah
as this was happening he started to kind
of come out of his shell and feeling the
weight of the world lifting from his
shoulders because finally his story is
gonna be told and signed by the world
Visa be mark ruffalo right and this film
and he starts to look like this
you see how handsome he is a little
glint in his eye and and you and there's
almost nothing that made us feel better
about watching us relieve him of the
burden that he'd been carrying
single-handedly what a wonderful kind of
like one-two punch with his work it's
like he did accomplish so much but now
the fact that this movie exists it's
like a whole nother wave of it I mean he
said to me when the New York Times
article landed he said he said to me and
mario kario this the writer one of the
writers on the script when we strove
with him from
from Cincinnati to partners where he
said when that article landed I knew at
least they weren't gonna kill me you
know like the isolation these kinds of
people are put into the danger zone that
they enter into the physical the
physical illness required still was
never sufficiently diagnosed and you're
taking on one of the biggest chemical
companies in the world it's hard to not
have some conspiratorial or paranoia a
trap attached to that but yeah so yes
this relieved him and unburdened him in
ways that we still see hearing you
describe so many of those features of
him is making me think of a lot of your
past work just like the idea of dealing
with isolation and and someone dealing
with like a something that's physical
and they can't really put a finger on
what it is do you think that this movie
kind of landed in your lap at the
perfect time or do you think you could
have made dark waters you know I don't
know 10 15 years ago it's funny mark has
been sort of responding to that very
question in QA as we've been having and
I agree with him that sometimes they're
sort of a zeitgeist but almost beckons
projects to come to the fore at the time
that they do you know it's there's
something in the air that makes them
necessary to happen when they happen and
and I do feel like just the
environmental issues that our country is
confronting and heading into an election
year and and the ways that our
regulatory system has so catered to the
needs of Industry how much money and big
business have dominated our economy
these are all things that make this an
incredibly relevant story to tell and
something that really we all felt really
needed to be told yeah one of the
reasons why it was happening it was
interesting seeing this so soon after I
went to TIFF and I saw that documentary
that Ellen Page had made and it's it is
about environmental racism it's called
there's something in the water and it's
her back in her hometown and Halifax and
just exploring that and I don't like
their difference in areas but they go
hand in hand and it just shows how
widespread these issues are Michigan
yeah we can go on and on and attach
these relevant stories because it's a
systemic problem and you're gonna see
all kinds of specific examples cropping
up in all these different places and you
can only focus on one thing at a time
and we wanted to enter this story
dramatically and with come with
compassion of the people involved and
make it something that people could
really experience and feel for yeah what
is it like condensing I mean I guess
this was essentially almost two decades
worth of research and work cuz you can't
fit it all in there so is there any
specific part about you know what
happened in this whole process that you
just hope people know about that maybe
you couldn't include in the movie I
think we hit the main points I mean
there's no question exactly as you
stayed you know a complicated legal
narrative like this Rob a lava is
actually just written a book called
exposure but really and really
compellingly lays out the far more
complex full story and we had the
dramatic task of trying to make it into
something that could be experienced by
an audience and a single viewing where I
think the best kinds of whistleblower
films you you know you follow the
overall momentum and the trajectory
forward and then the the two steps back
one step forward process that always
happens right but you can't possibly
maintain and understand every single
aspect of either the legal discourse or
the journalistic discourse if that's the
the theme of the film but you but it's
all there and you feel like it's being
supported on solid ground but that's not
really the point the point is to watch
this overall progression that real
people take and risk their lives over
and I think that's what we tried to
accomplish oh yeah absolutely as far as
the the journalism and the legal jargon
goes though is there any particular bit
that you found the hardest to convey
clearly where you had a workshop at a
little in order to get it to screen the
best way I think I mean this this was
really the brainchild of Mario Correa
the second screenwriter became when our
first screenwriter got busy shooting a
movie of his own and we brought Mario in
and it was fantastic but the way the
centerpiece of the film is really the
presentation of the story that Rob has
investigated through
the discovery process that really is the
UH the shocking backstory of DuPont and
Teflon right there knowing history
polluting and dumping the toxic
byproducts of PFOA into the water
systems and into the air and so you see
him going through all the material and
researching but you're kind of kept at a
distance from it and then finally he
lands in his kitchen one night with his
wife and he's throwing away his Teflon
and she's like Rob what's going on and
he says I gotta tell you what's been
going on and they sit down in the
kitchen table and he starts to tell him
the story and it sort of intercuts with
it goes back to his process of
discovering the story putting all
together but he tells it first to Sara
and then we intercut with him telling it
to Tim Robbins and then to Victor Garber
who plays the lawyer from the pond and
it's particularly sort of the
centerpiece of the film but it's so
important you know and I think what we
wanted to feel is that the audience was
ready to hear this story when it finally
lands how many times do you get to shoot
a scene as intense as that because that
to me is one of the highlights for mark
ruffle and also for Anne Hathaway from a
performance perspective but it looks
like you know that's one of those things
where it takes a lot of answers out of
someone so is it a you know try to shoot
that and get in the can as quick as
possible the sheer amount of lines that
Mark had to memorize and present to her
but do it in a you know balancing that
thing where he's not an actor he's not
an activist he's a lawyer
and he's in the present tense of his own
discovery process and so he wanted him
to be very present and very measured
about the way he described it and told
it to the to his wife but he had to
recite pages of dialogue and I just
couldn't i sat there I was like holy
[ __ ] you know he's he's so prepared I
mean the guy is so conscientious and so
devoted and such an incredibly warm
and you know just sympathetic and
empathetic presence onset I feel like
you can totally tell there can right
when someone has that quality I feel
like no matter what role they're in it
kind of like radiates off the screen and
you feel it's really true definitely
feel it from him how do you go about as
far as the visuals go making you know
rifling through papers something you
know exciting and even boardroom scenes
you have a couple boardroom scenes that
really just you know up the energy of
the movie when you're essentially just
shooting a whole bunch of people sitting
at a table yeah you know we I tried to
sort of set up this this style that this
visual style this visual language sort
of the sort of temperament of the movie
that had a sort of restraint that had a
sort of emotional coolness because it
reflected Rob and it also reminded me of
the way some of my favorite films like
from the 1970s that Gordon Willis shot
you know with Alec cool parallax view
cloud and of course all the President's
Men among all the other amazing things
he shot in the 70s have this observation
all sort of elegance and it trusts the
performers the frame trust the
performances and the material and lets
the the frame come alive with what's
happening with great actors and I had
great actors and I you know looked at
those movies for inspiration and sort of
feeling secure yeah we can we can trust
our audiences we don't the cot and be
all flashy yeah you know and I think I
think that comes through and I think
it's true to rob a lot there's this is
like one very specific thing that I
notice and I hope I can kind of like
pinpoint the right scene without
spoiling it for everybody but there's
one particular boardroom scene where Tim
Robbins has like an exceptional moment
and it's a moment that I would assume a
director would be getting closer and
closer and closer on the person talking
in order to up the intensity but know
you like in the heat of his speech you
go back to a wide shot in whole and see
the whole room I'm just curious what was
what was the thought behind that
particular choice because I was
surprised how well that played
thank you that's nice um well we it was
a long and complicated scene with many
different parts it's really also where
Rob really is there to convince the
partners at his firm to take on this
massive class action case this is a law
firm that had never taken on a class
action case they're not plaintiffs
attorneys they're defense attorneys and
so it took a lot of convincing and I was
gonna challenge the reputation of what
this law firm stood for and so we
covered it amply it's a five minute long
scene in the movie but I was always so
happy to hear when we were testing the
movie and we were showing it to
audiences that one of their favorite
films are the scenes of the film was
this one absolutely visually potentially
the least visually compelling but I
think the framing works
the triangular room that it was
reflected by the actual interior of the
true Taft offices this architecture that
we that I love that we honored in this
set we built to match that but really
it's it's William Jackson Harper it's
it's Tim Robbins and it's Rob and it's
Mark Roth
William Jackson Harper's have been quite
the year - I love seeing him pop up all
over the place that particular scene
it's like what he's saying it's so
important for the entirety of the
company that it wasn't until after I
watch it that I'm like like I needed
that I needed to feel the impact of that
on every single person around that table
absolutely yeah I just love that
particular shot I also really wanted to
ask you about working with participant
media and this is a very convoluted way
to ask this question but it's like we're
constantly talking now about movies
getting you know the budget to make it
on the big screen and it's only the
biggest of the big and not these small
movies but participant is a company that
is always making movies with purpose and
always helping to fun movies with value
like that so what was your experience
like working with them and yeah where do
you see them going as a company in the
future that could help the film industry
well they're so rare as a studio that
has the mandate of social justice themed
films I mean that's an extraordinary
hand just there we can all stop
for a second ago wow that's
extraordinary right but the fact that
they've had tremendous success and many
of these films I mean even just last
year between Green Book and Roma they're
very very different Philips and maybe
they divided or separated audiences but
you can't not admire the fact that both
of these films pass through the hands of
participant right and and they've been
involved with Spielberg's films that
have had social themes to them and they
acquire documentaries and they create
documentary material and so so the the
breadth of their commitment is so
serious and so evident in the films that
they've done but thank God they've also
had success and that can fortify that
mandate and take it further absolutely I
mean between them and Focus Features
it's like the second you put their name
on a movie you're gonna get my attention
absolutely I've been very very lucky to
stumble into that for sure one of the
questions that I've gotten in the habit
of asking a lot of directors now because
someone recently brought up to me it's
like when you're an actor you get to act
on set opposite your peers and see how
other people work that doesn't
necessarily happen with a director so if
you had the opportunity to be a fly on
the wall of another director set who
would you choose and why
living dad could be either that's too
hard I think the last person I spoke to
picked I think it was Kubrick right I
mean it's it's it's a it's a hard one to
settle I'll pick somebody more obscure
okay I would have Kubrick on my list I
would have hid about somebody the
Scorsese on my list no doubt but Max
Ophuls
was is one of my favorite filmmakers and
he was idolized by Kubrick and Kubrick
described Max Ophuls camera as something
that floats through walls and Max Ophuls
worked in Europe and he did a few a
handful of films in America and then he
went back to Europe and did his final
film Lola Montez at the sort of a very
end of the 1940s but the films are
southern I'm sorry was if it was the 50s
the films are so exquisite the way
they're crafted he also a try
acted very awesome progressive minded
writers and actors to do extraordinary
things together bigger scale and smaller
scale in Europe and America letters from
a known nun woman reckless moment and
caught are the three movies he made in
America back to back in the 40s and they
are just among my favorite I can watch
them over and over and I learn something
every time it's one of the best kinds of
movies right there thank you so much for
your time today guys dark water is in
theaters November 22nd it's a good day
it's my birthday so it's Mark Ruffalo's
birthday not bad I happily take it all
they see all the good vibes go into your
movie right now so I'm down check it out
when it hits theaters again thank you so
much for your time today we are gonna
have more exclusive Collider interviews
coming your way real soon